okay so the Dom contains all the content
of the page the CSS on contains all the
styles of the page so how do we take the
content in styles and turn them into
pixels on the screen I feel like we're
missing an intermediate step
that's good intuition now we need to
combine the DOM and the CSS on trees
into the render tree which will capture
exactly what you described one of the
most important properties of the render
tree is that it only captures visible
content and to see this in action let's
work through the simple example we have
in front of us at the top we have the
Dom tree and at the bottom the CSS
object model to construct the render
tree we start at the root of the Dom
tree which in this case is the paragraph
node and check if there are any CSS
rules that match it in this case we see
that we do have a matching rule that
makes all the text render in 16 pixel
font size and in bold so we copy the
paragraph node to our render tree
alongside with its CSS properties okay
we're done with the paragraph note let's
walk down the tree next we see hello
which is just a text node so we copy
that to our render tree next we arrive
at the span node we have a matching CSS
rule for it we have a span and it is
indeed a child of the paragraph node but
notice that one of the properties in
this rule is that it's marked as
display:none which tells us that the
contents of the span should not be
rendered and since as we said the render
tree only captures visible content we
can skip it and its children we skip to
children because display:none cascades
down right exactly and as a result we
can skip all the children nodes of the
span node and go to the next node which
in this case is just another text node
and we copied that to our render tree
once over so the render tree captures
both the content and the styles right
now let's take a look at our hello world
page okay here we have the DOM and CSS
elm trees for our hello world page to
build a render tree we start at the HTML
node in the Dom tree the HTML and
sections don't contain any visible
information so we can just quickly prune
them out of our Rena tree next we have
the body node let's copy that over this
left part of the tree should look
familiar this is what we just built so
let's copy that over as well finally we
have the div and the image nodes both of
these contain visible contents so we
also copied them over and their styles
into our render tree with that done
compare this render tree to what we have
on the screen huh yeah the render tree
is a pretty good representation the
unnecessary tax is gone I can see that
there should be an image on the screen
and it should be displayed on the right
so are we all done now not quiet we
still have to do layout but first a
quick quiz